aujourd'hui je vous présente une recette
de mon pays d'origine le liban
c'est l'hiver il fait froid alors rien
de tel qu'une soupe pour se réchauffer
on commence donc par couper un gros
oignon des et on le fait bondir d'un 4
cuillères à soupe d'huile d'olive on
ajoute ensuite 300 g de lentilles sèche
et 6 verres d'eau le repas du soir c'est
bien qu'ils soient pas trop craint voilà
parce que avoir eu un bol alimentaire
gravats va ralentir la vidange gastrique
c'est à dire que ça va ralentir ou fait
la digestion pour nous c'est le moment
de passer à la pomme de terre
cette pomme de terre coupées en tout
petit cube qu'on ne sentira quasiment
plus à la fin et pour les saveurs on
assaisonne avec 2 cuillères à soupe de
cumin et une seule de 4 épices pendant
que ça mijote on mixe de la coriandre
fraîche avec 4 gousses d'ail ont fait
revenir à la casserole la moitié de la
préparation avec un peu d'huile d'olive
et quand les odeurs mon top tôt dans la
marmite notre set est quasiment terminée
la soupe cuit doucement je n'ai plus
qu'à préparer les blettes légumes
d'hiver par excellence on ne garde que
la partie verte couper les feuilles en
lamelles attention par contre les
légumes doivent rejoindre la marmite que
dix minutes avant de la fin de cuisson
des lentilles donc là elle associe à la
fois les féculents avec les lentilles et
les légumes
tout ça sous forme de potages dont
kassav à hydrater le corps pour la
touche finale un peu de sel et du jus de
citron selon votre envie ajouté sur le
dessus le reste de la coriandre et voilà
la soupe qui réchauffe aussi bien les
corps que les coeurs et qui fait voyager
loin sans avoir besoin d'acheter des
billets